all right I I want to look at a couple
different things that my colleague John
actually sent me some of you may
remember this uh black Maga Pastor Jesse
Lee Peterson he's been on the program
before I've been on his show before in
Los Angeles California he recently was
involved in I think it's fair to call it
a scandal where despite leading a life
of public homophobic advocacy about
being gay is bad and demoral and all
these different things it appears that
Jesse Lee Peterson himself is is gay and
um this exploded in controversy several
months ago somehow Jesse Lee Peterson
ended up on the Dr Phil show now I'm
gonna be totally up front I I don't
think much of the Dr Phil show and in
fact I had some back and forths with
them about two months ago about having
me on they wasted my time they were
completely disrespectful of my time
asking me to do a pre-interview and a
video Vlog explaining My Views a uh of
filling out providing answers to dozens
of questions then they never even told
me hey turns out we're not going to have
you on just never even followed up one
of the most unprofessional outfits I've
ever dealt with and yet I'm still going
to play this for you with peace and love
because it is so absolutely fascinating
Jesse Lee Peterson somehow ended up on
the Dr Phil Show and by the way this guy
on the screen right now is not Jesse Lee
Peterson I I'm aware of that
um and he just said violent disgusting
things that actually made an audience
member cry let's just jump right into
this first clip the the topic was is it
smart to have children now in the
background of all of this with Jesse Lee
Peterson is his personal situation where
he says he sell he told me he was
celibate because he's not married and it
turns out it's not just that he's not
married to a woman it's it's that he's
actually gay and is hiding these
relationships it's crazy Let's Just Jump
Right In
I I just glue it all this crap that I
hear I grew up with six brothers and
Seven Sisters at a time when you know I
grew up by the way it's funny that they
identify him as radio host and Pastor
which is like so banal and anodyne
in the context of how whacked completely
whacked this guy is the plantation in
Alabama and we grew up in a little Hut
house bathroom outside and we my family
of uh raised an amazing family children
but what the difference was then that it
is now is that before you have babies
you got married ah so you have the
father and a mother in the home and
while the fathers are earning a living
the mother was watching over his
children and so you were this entire
routine is soap extra hypocritical and
ridiculous and absurd given what we now
know about Jesse Lee Peterson personally
it's stunning that he still goes around
and says this stuff with a straight face
even to raise decent children we didn't
have government in our lives at the time
and so we were able to do that and in
America we were not allowed all these
illegal aliens and refugees to come into
our country so our government that we're
not taking care of folks from other
parts of the world and the families in
America we took care of ourselves I
think you've
oh my God people in the audience visibly
rolling their eyes but eventually they
cry
pretty much
pissed off everybody
but you said you said there's not
anything you've heard that you don't
think is crap so what do you think you
said what you don't think what do you
think I know that we need to restore the
family we need a smaller government
because government don't make anything
work understand that the family Jesse
Lee Peterson says must be restored which
is a man and a woman married having many
children is something that he himself
doesn't actually live by because it
appears as though he's a gay man which
is fine but he's spent decades shaming
gay men it's absolutely disgusting and
then a little bit later in the show his
comments actually so vile that they make
audience members who are immigrants
break down in tears what do you want to
say I would like to speak to you guys
directly you two
um to your point that four children are
the worst in the world and that
immigrants are also also not a good
thing for this country I'm someone who
grew up in an orphanage in Russia I
lived there for 12 years and then I came
to the United States
and I've been working campus hours at
sorry at the um La food bank and in the
um skid row and I just think it's so
messed up when you guys are saying I'm
sorry I don't mean to be crying it's
okay
just talk through the tears I want to
hear what Dr Phil's like please no cry
more keep talking as you cry it's good
for the ratings what do you have to say
ah
I'm someone who came from Russia and
I've been putting in countless hours
working volunteering
for people in Skid Row but what you
don't realize for example to you that we
are not the worst people in the world
right I've been mentoring young guys
since I was 18 from the ages of 14
through 24. yeah I grew up in the inner
city of Detroit there's this weird thing
about the Dr Phil show where so we know
Jesse Lee Peterson is completely vile I
don't know that we need too much of a
commentary on that there's this weird
vibe on the Dr Phil show where it's sort
of like they try to present it like a
serious show but it kind of has like
Jerry Springer Maury Povich Vibes and I
don't know it's it's like every detail
something about the way it's filmed
something about the lighting and the
color temperature the lower thirds and
the font even I I can't exactly put my
finger on what it is but it just feels
like one of those types of shows even
though it kind of seems like they're
taking themselves seriously bizarre
stuff I don't even know how much Dr
Phil's people knew about Jesse Lee
Peterson when they had him on but quite
literally saying things so disgusting
they make members of the audience cry
strange and bizarre stuff